أنا فقط أريده أن
يعود
عندما بدا كايل دوان ، البالغ من العمر خمس سنوات ، أن الماء
بدا هادئًا ، يسرد والده الآن
كلمات الصبي الأخيرة
لأمه أنه كان يخبر والدتها أنه
بخير ،
هل كل شيء على ما يرام
ولكن الأب يقول أن الماء اقتلع
كايل بعيدًا عن  ذراعي والدته
صباح يوم الاثنين
بينما كانت تخرجه وتحاول
حمله ، كان التيار
هناك ، فقد سمع شاشتها من
قبل السكان القريبين الذين فعلوا كل ما في
وسعهم للمساعدة ، ثم تمكنت
من إحضار حبل لها والحصول عليها  كانت
على الجانب لكنهم لم يتمكنوا من
الوصول إلى ابني ،
أم الزوج الذي كان هناك رآه
كان يطفو إلى الوراء وكان رأسه فوق
الماء كان ينظر إلى الخارج
[موسيقى]
وكانت هذه آخر مرة رأوه فيها
الآن نفي صادم  وحسرة قلب
زوجتي ، الأمر صعب حقًا لأنها
نجت من الحدث
ولم يكن موجودًا هنا وتشعر بالذنب حقًا لأنها لم تكن
من تنزل إليه وليس هو
لم ترغب في تناول الطعام ، فقد رفضت
قالت إذا كان ابني موجودًا هناك  لا
أريد أن أذهب  سواء
كان مقطع فيديو منزلي محبب من ماضي عيد الميلاد ،
الآن ذكرى عزيزة كبيرة واحدة كبيرة
، كان طفلاً جيدًا ، كان لديه الكثير من الأصدقاء الذين
تحبهم لمساعدة المعلم ، أعني
أنه كان طفلاً في روضة الأطفال
، وكان يقوم بتجارب جديدة
، وهو  ربما مثل الكثير من الأطفال الذين
تعرفهم عندما تكون في منطقتك
ولكن العائلة مصممة على العثور على
كايل شقيقه الأكبر تايلر يبحث
بمساعدة الأصدقاء
ولأول مرة الأربعاء أرى
سيارة والدته أنا فقط  غير قادر على الكلام من رؤية
هذا النوع من اندفاع المشاعر ،
ولكن هناك الكثير مما يحدث الآن بينما
يبحث عن أخيه الصغير ، لقد
ذكره بالبهجة التي
جلبها للعائلة ،
(تصفيق
) يستيقظ جميع أفراد الأسرة
كل صباح
لقد كان على معظمنا أن ينام في
أم حاول على الأقل وهو الشخص
الذي يخرجنا من سريرها كل
يوم
ويبحث مجتمع بأكمله على أمل
أن تجده الذي تريده
ولكنك لا تريد ذلك  كن من يجد
هو ونعم ،
إنه أمر مخيف ،
لكننا نريدهم فقط
أن يكتشفوا أن المساعدة والدعم التي
تقول عائلة جوان إنها تمنحهم
القوة كثيرًا مما
يمنحني الكثير من الأصدقاء الذين
يحاولون موازنة الأمل في وجه كايل المبتسم
مقابل الواقع القاتم.  سيكون
الأمر صعبًا في مرحلة ما ، سيكون الأمر
صعبًا حقًا
وأخبرني الأب أنه
يفهم أن هذه قد تكون عملية تعافي ،
ومع ذلك
تستأنف Caitlyn البحث عندما تشرق الشمس